well now's as good a time as any to go
over some interesting and very useful
properties of the Laplace transform and
the first is to show that it is a linear
operator what does that mean well let's
say I wanted to take the Laplace
transform the Laplace transform of the
sum of that we call it the weighted sum
of two functions so say some constant c1
times my first function f of t plus some
constant c2 times my second function G
of T well by the definition of the
Laplace transform this would be equal to
the improper integral from 0 to infinity
of e to the minus s T times whatever our
our function that we're taking the
Laplace transform of total times c1 F of
T plus c2 G of T I think you know where
this is going all of that DT and then
that is equal to integral from 0 to
infinity let's just distribute the e to
the minus s T that is equal to what that
is equal to c1 c1 e to the minus st f of
t plus c2 e to the minus st g of t and
all of that times DT and just by the
definition of how or the properties of
integrals work we know that we can split
this up into two integrals right if the
the integral of the sum of two functions
is equal to the sum of their integrals
and these are just constants so this is
going to be equal to c1 times the
integral from zero to infinity of e to
the minus st times f of t DF t plus c2
times
integral from zero to infinity of e to
the minus s T G of T DT and this was
just a very long-winded way of saying
well you know what is this this is the
Laplace transform of F of T this is the
Laplace transform of G of T so this is
equal to c1 times the Laplace transform
of F of T plus c2 times this is the
Laplace transform the Laplace transform
of G of T and so we have just shown that
the Laplace transform is a linear
operator right the Laplace transform of
this is equal to this
so essentially you can kind of break up
the sum and go and you know take out the
constants and just take the Laplace
transform
that's something useful to know and you
might have guessed that that was the
case anyway but now you know for sure
now we'll do something which I consider
even more interesting and and this is
actually going to be a big clue as to
why the plus transforms are extremely
are extremely useful for solving
differential equations so let's say I
want to find the Laplace transform the
Laplace transform of F prime of T so I
have some F of T I take its derivative
and then I want the Laplace transform of
that let's see if we can find a
relationship between the Laplace
transform of the derivative of a
function and the Laplace transform of
the function so we're going to use some
integration by parts here so let's let's
just put the integration well actually
let me just say what this is first of
all this is equal to the integral from 0
to infinity of e to the minus st times F
prime of T F prime of T DT and to solve
this we're going to use integration by
parts I let me write it in the corner
just we remember what it is so I think I
memorize it because I recorded that last
video not too long ago that the
integrals can write the shorthand the
integral of u
of you what's a UV prime because that'll
match what we have up here better is
equal to the both functions without the
derivatives you V minus the integral of
the opposite so the opposite is U prime
V U prime V so here the substitution is
pretty clear right because we don't want
it we want to end up with we want to end
up with a with f of X right so let's
make V prime is f Prime and let's make
you eat ooh the minus SD so let's do
that U is going to be e to the minus st
and V is going to equal what V is you
going to equal F prime of T and then u
prime u prime would be minus s e to the
minus st and then and then V prime oh
sorry this is V Prime
right right V prime is f prime of T V
prime is is F prime of T so V is just
going to be equal to F of T hope I
didn't say that wrong the first time but
you see what I'm saying this is you
that's U and this is V Prime and if this
is V prime then if you take the
antiderivative both sides and V is equal
to f of T so let's apply integration by
parts so this Laplace transform which is
this is equal to UV which is equal to e
to the minus s T this is equal e to the
minus s T times V F of T F of t minus
minus the integral minus the integral
and of course we're going to have to
evaluate this from 0 to infinity I'll
keep the I'll keep the
the improper integral with us the whole
time I won't switch back and forth
between the the definite and indefinite
integral so - this part so the integral
and from 0 to infinity of u prime u
prime is minus s e to the minus s T
times V V is f of T f of T DT now let's
see we have a - a - let's make both of
these pluses this s is just a constant
so we can bring it out so that is equal
to that is equal to e to the minus s T F
of T evaluated from 0 to infinity or as
we approach infinity plus s times the
integral from 0 to infinity of e to the
minus s T F of T DT and here we see what
is this this is the Laplace transform of
F of T right so this is equal to let's
evaluate this part so when we evaluated
infinity as we approach infinity e to
the minus infinity is approach 0 F of
infinity now this is an interesting
question this is an interesting question
F of infinity I don't know that could be
large that could be small that could
approach some that approaches some value
right this approaches 0 so we're not
sure if this if this increases faster
than this approaches 0 then this will
diverge I won't go into into the
mathematics of whether this converges or
diverges but let's just say in very
rough terms that this will converge to 0
if F of T grows slower then e to the
minus st shrinks and I'll maybe later on
we'll do some more rigorous definitions
of under what conditions will F of T
actually will this expression actually
converge but let's assume that F of T
grows slower than e to the S T or it
converges it would grow slower than this
then this then this or diverges slower
than this converge is another way to
view it or this grow slower than this
shrinks so if this grow slower than this
shrinks then this whole expression will
approach zero and then you want to
subtract this whole expression evaluated
at 0 so e to the 0 is 1 my times F of 0
so that's just F of 0 F of 0 plus s
times we said this is the Laplace
transform of F of T that's our
definition so the Laplace transform of F
of T and now we have an interesting
property what was the left-hand side of
everything we were doing the Laplace
transform of F prime of T so let me just
write it all over again so we now know
that and I'll switch colors the Laplace
transform of F prime of T is equal to s
times the Laplace transform of F of t
minus F of 0 and now let's just let's
just extend this further what is the
Laplace transform and this is a really
useful thing to know what is the Laplace
transform of F prime prime of T well we
can do a little pattern matching here
right that's going to be s times the
Laplace transform of its antiderivative
times the Laplace transform of F prime
of T right this goes to this that's an
antiderivative this goes to this that's
one antiderivative minus F prime of 0
right but then what's the Laplace
transform of this this is going to be
equal to s times the Laplace transform
of F prime of T but what's that that's
this right that's s times the Laplace
transform of F of T
- f of zero right I just substituted
this with this - f prime of zero and we
get the Laplace transform of the second
derivative is equal to s squared times
the Laplace transform of our function f
of t minus s times f of zero minus F
prime of zero and I think you're
starting to see a pattern here this is a
little a strand form of F prime prime of
T and I think you're trying to see why
the Laplace transform is useful it turns
derivatives into multiplication in two
multiplications by s and actually as
you'll see later it turns in terms
integration - divisions by s and you can
take you can take our [ __ ] derivatives
and just keep multiplying by s and you
see this pattern and and I'm running out
of time but I'll leave it up to you to
figure out what the Laplace transform of
the third derivative of F is see you in
the next video